every year the world's most elite  mountain bikers gather in france for a  race unlike any other  it's  the longest  tony race in the world  that's right mcavalanch is the longest  downhill race in the world  18 miles long 10 000 feet high in the  french alps and a crazy starting line of  3 000 cyclists on a mountain peak  this is remy absalon he won the  mcavalence  i started mountain bike when i was young  enduro and mountain bike is  really cool because we can explore all  around the world  mecca avalanche alperus takes place  since the french alps  in halperduez so not so far of italy and  switzerland  it's  really high in harps so you have a  very good  view 360 degrees  around  you  it's really crazy i don't know why  i do that  you ride all kinds of terrain  first the glacier and after the rocky  section the forest  is very physical with  some herpes so when you cross the line  and you are first  you're really happy and  you want to try again  you